what is your favorite rom-com it's a
rom-com Peppa Pig os1 before there's a
French movie named babysitting it's
hilarious who is your favorite
non-basketball athlete Joey Chestnut no
I'm kidding pearly and Bobby what will
be your first big purchase big foreign
[Music]
what is something a player does right
now that you want
I've been working a little bit on my
Skyhook you know Kareem Skyhook and
hopefully someday can be a weapons who
was your favorite person to go to in
times of Crisis no brainer my siblings
you know it's just we're like one person
we're three but we're like one person
what is your favorite food I really love
my my grandma where are you most excited
in the United States it's gonna be like
the big big Landscapes we see in like uh
Colorado like even even California the
big national parks